[Musik]
gut der astra mediation eure
fahrzeuge ins park passiert wir haben in
den alarm statt auf den flugobjekten gar
nicht wissen wo das herkommt wer das ist
und hier demonstriert - bei der herr
bauer mit einer c 130 hercules der
indischen luftstreitkräfte und die
holter forderte klinke sich bereits auf
der piste und ziehen die reinen abfahren
der eurofighter ist in der lage bis zu 2
fache schallgeschwindigkeit also über
2000 heimat zu fliegen und haben dort
eine strecke rasch zu überwinden deshalb
ist es notwendig ein überschallflugzeug
in österreich zu haben sie vor ort ein
zielobjekt nähern wir uns an zuerst
unerkannt werden der auftrag der geht
wir mögen das flugzeug weg begleiten und
auf eine frequenz zu bringen gehen wir
auch in sichtweite und da kann man schon
so an 50 meter an die tragflächen
spitzen des abfangjägers herangeführt
werden er erbat 22 zeigen wir im lande
zu sagen die c-130 wird natürlich da den
eurofightern folge leisten so wie wir
das erwarten und inzell begleiten und
damit ist einmal die ab von
demonstrationen durchgeführt
[Musik]